phoning it in bud how are you great man
it's been
it has to be tough i need a lot of rain
this week a lot of subpar golf you must
have been
kind of slugging through a long week of
golf huh i guess man who even wants to
play golf that's my question
i i actually missed my cousin's
circumcision for this
i was in the city doing a shell game
with a couple of buddies
and i got a twit that said a we're on
beth page black at the seventh hole
i thought it was a porn so i drove out
here
and uh apparently there's a lot of golf
going on
but not much sex yeah not well there's a
little bit
i caught a bj in a sand trap
yeah and i wouldn't recommend that but
glover won
uh but the news is that he's not black
that was the surprising news i was like
glover not black that's a bigger story
no relation to danny out there
no relation to danny or leroy glover
actually who retired today after 13
seasons in the nfl nice now not to bring
up a touchy subject for you but you
mentioned that bj in the sand trap any
sign of crabs
um not here phil mickelson lost
he came in second i don't know if he has
crabs or not
uh his wife has cancer though and we
wish her well
much more serious disease nice uh any
did you get did you get to meet any of
your favorite players out there anybody
were looking forward to meeting
no i saw john sally with a couple of
white chicks
uh so that was pretty cool and i got one
of their autographs
so the girls he hangs out with can
actually write their own names now uh
yeah it wasn't in cursive
first time covered in golf i take it
yeah definitely my first time covering
golf and hopefully my last there's a lot
of cars here driving back on the course
too which is really dangerous at this uh
at this hour
they're actually about to film a subaru
commercial out here
uh which actually might be more exciting
than this year's u.s
open and i also couldn't help but notice
that i believe there's a palm tree
behind you
yeah there's a poem here uh they brought
in a couple of poems this year uh
just because tiger woods it was in his
contract
it was in his contract that he had to
have uh that he had to have palms
new york has never looked better and i'm
also pleased to see that it's still
daytime where you are because
it is it's bright forever uh here in new
york
alaska well theo we appreciate it was
always taking time from your shell game
and your autograph collecting to join us
here on sportsmanship
um theo vaughn everybody corresponded
give it up for them all right
three card money
you